- Good evening everyone,
thank you for joining us.
For those of you who don't
already know me, I'm Lynn Cooley,
the Dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences.
I'm very pleased to welcome
you to our first presentation
in a series of conversations
with Yale Graduate School Alumni,
sponsored by the graduate
school and its alumni board.
This series called "Perspectives"
is meant to bridge our alumni
and student communities,
sharing alumni experiences and insights
as both models for success
and to open opportunities
for alumni and students to connect.
I have ambitious goals for transforming
and evolving Yale's approach
to doctoral education,
as well as plans to strengthen
and build our alumni community,
to connect our faculty, administrators,
and students more frequently,
and to help ignite these connections
in support of our students.
I look forward to using what
we learned from this series
to think about how we can continue
to improve graduate student
experiences for all students.
So today we will be joined
by Charles D. Brown II,
PhD alumnus from the
Department of Physics,
as well as Jia Chen,
who is our vice chair of the
Graduate School Alumni Board,
and Matthew Tanico assistant
Dean for Graduate Student Life
in the graduate school.
We hope that you will
enjoy this conversation
about Charles's scholarship
and the lessons he has learned
from his days as a
graduate student at Yale.
I'm really glad to have graduate students,
alumni and faculty and old
friends of Charles tuning in,
from around the world,
and I hope you will
enjoy the conversation.
- Hi everyone, good evening.
My name is Matthew Tanico
and as Lynn mentioned,
I'm the assistant Dean
for Graduate Student Life here at Yale.
Before we get started,
I wanna share a few
housekeeping items with you.
We'll be recording this webinar
and we'll share the recording
after the conversation.
We're also offering closed captioning
and you can control that via the button
on the bottom of your screen.
In the second half of the session,
we'll be saving some time
for questions and answers.
Many graduate students and alumni
have submitted questions in advance,
but we also hope that you'll
enter additional questions
using the Q and A feature at
the bottom of your screen.
I will be moderating this discussion
with my fellow alum, Jia Chen,
vice chair of the Graduate
School Alumni Association Board,
who is a Yale GSAS alumni from
the Department of Physics,
I'll rely on her for the technical
background as a humanist.
Now I'm delighted to
introduce Charles D. Brown II,
Charles received his PhD in
physics from Yale in 2019,
and is currently a National
Academies of Science Engineering
and Medicine Ford Foundation,
postdoctoral fellow
in the ultra cold atomic physics group
in the Department of Physics
at the University of California, Berkeley,
as well as co-founder
and co-lead organizer
of hashtag BlackInPhysics Week,
a week dedicated to celebrating
the historical contributions
of black physicists,
welcome Jia and Charles.
- Thank you very much, Matthew,
thank you, Dean Lynn Cooley,
thank you for this opportunity.
So I am the vice chair of the
Graduate School Alumni Board,
and I'm delighted to have this opportunity
to pose a first question
to our guest Charles.
Charles, I noticed actually
last week you gave a talk
at our physics club
about a complex topic of
lattice trapped quantum gas,
so very interesting.
I wonder whether the talk
was virtual, in person
or it's a hybridization
of giving a virtual conference on campus.
But we'd like to ask you about
your research in grad school
and your work in current role
and how that work evolved.
- I'm happy to talk about that,
but first, thank you very
much for having me here,
I'm very excited to have this opportunity
to talk with you all
about a series of very
important topics to me.
But to the research, so as a PhD student,
I worked in a field called opto-mechanics,
opto referring to light,
mechanics referring to some
sort of oscillatory motion
of an object in the field
where the light or in the
area where the light exists.
So it turns out that
if you can confine some amount
of light to some geometry,
and you can oscillate
some object within it,
you can produce an
interaction between the light
and the mechanical
object that's oscillating
in a way where they
sort of mutually affect
each other's behavior.
It turns out that you can
use that system potentially
to do some very technologically
interesting things.
For example,
do networking between
different kinds of devices,
perhaps quantum computing devices,
when they exist in the future,
you need to sort of have
them talk to each other
and opto-mechanical platform
is an interesting one
to do that sort of work.
It also turns out that if you
want to do something like,
test the limits of quantum mechanics,
if you wanna see sort of how
big a mechanical object can be,
a massive object can be and
still exhibit quantum behavior,
sort of almost wacky physics behavior
that you don't see in your normal life
or normal wing scales,
an opto-mechanical system
is an interesting one to use
to try to really understand
what is the limits of the size of a system
in which you can see quantum mechanics.
And so in my PhD,
I did things like,
have light interact with
density fluctuations
in a really special kind of way,
that was sort of half of
my time in grad school.
The other half of my time in grad school
was building a new,
very interesting system,
which involved levitating
a drop of superfluid liquid helium,
this is a very interesting state of matter
that flows with zero viscosity.
You can use very powerful magnetics,
magnetic fields to levitate that liquid,
and you can shine lasers on it
where some of the light will
get trapped inside of the drop
and that light will interact
with the drop's vibrations.
So now you have a new kind
of opto-mechanical system
that's well isolated from its environment,
and so well-positioned to eventually study
some interesting quantum
physics phenomenon.
Now as a postdoc, I do
something quite different,
but still quantum
mechanics, quantum physics
is at the heart of what I study.
So to sort of introduce this,
it's useful to think
about solid materials,
a solid say a crystal,
it is a periodic arrangement of ions
where electrons hop back and forth
between the different positions of ions.
Of the hopping of those
electrons around the material,
determines a lot of the
materials properties.
Now you can make a lattice
completely out of light,
this is what I do now,
and you can make atoms
really, really cold,
you can throw those atoms into
that lattice made of light,
and those atoms will
hop around the lattice.
And it turns out that this
platform is a nice system
to sort of simulate a real solid crystal,
but our system is on a larger scale,
it's easier to image,
everything is slowed down
and more easily measurable
with our current technology,
and so we can use these
sort of quantum simulation experiments
to gain insight into the
quantum physics of materials
in a way that is difficult
for people that study this sort of physics
in solid materials.
And it's all sort of a platform
to start learning about how,
when you have a large system
with many interacting particles
where quantum mechanics is important,
sort of how does the system behave?
There's lots of open and very
interesting questions there,
and so now I'm geared
towards trying to address
those sorts of questions.
- Very fascinating, Charles, wow.
Mathew what do you think?
- Yeah, no, thank you.
Sorry (laughing drowns speaker's words)
problems that we have.
No, that was amazing Charles.
Can you talk a little
bit about the sort of
move that you've made in your own career,
and I wanna talk a little bit about
the hashtag BlackInPhysics
week that you started.
Some of our fellow Alumni
Association board members
actually came across your article,
which is part of the reason
why we wanted to bring you
to be in conversation
with us this evening.
And you've written in you're
somewhat scholarly work,
I would still call it that,
about your own experiences
with bias and anti-blackness
within the academy.
And so as a result of that,
those experiences, you started
hashtag black in physics.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about the initiative,
but also about some of those experiences
that you felt both as a graduate student
and in your current role as a postdoc,
but more generally as a physicist?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So I actually have a lot to
say here, as you might imagine,
but I think I can sort of
quickly sum up my experiences
in the academy with the idea that,
as I wrote in the "Physics
Today" article you're referencing
"This and Taking the
Anti-blackness from Physics,"
many of my experiences as a student,
involved people who had
a hard time understanding
that I was part of the
intellectual community.
And so it was often the case
that I was sort of thought to
not belong in certain spaces
and that made for very
difficult interactions,
and it was sort of the
buildup of this over years,
that was very difficult.
And you know, this is not a
problem you'd meet to Yale,
this is a problem that sort of happens
when you have a very
small number of people
that look like me
in a space where the people
who make up the majority
of the institution,
aren't used to seeing
people like me around.
Or maybe haven't even had
many previous experiences
interacting with say black people,
oh, that was surprising,
let alone in an intellectual capacity.
So I think that has summed
up many of my experiences
as a student at Yale,
and it has also played a part
in some of my experiences
as a postdoc here at Berkeley.
So let me address BlackInPhysics.
So I guess the question is
sort of why did it come about?
Well, BlackInPhysics was
born during a moment of chaos
as a way for the community
of black physicists
to come together and gain a foothold
as the world around us
seem to be on shaky ground.
Another organization,
the National Society of Black Physicists
started in an important aspect
of this community building work,
and it's been doing so for decades,
but on our side,
we wanted to sort of further
build such a community
based on modern social media tools
that grant a new level of global access,
and allow for new ways
for distant individuals
to engage and remain
engaged with each other.
Part of our goal with BlackInPhysics
is to paint a more complete picture
of what a physicist looks like.
Unfortunately only about
3% of physics bachelors
go to black physicists,
and only 2% of PhDs go
to black physicists.
This necessarily means that
the number of black physicists
in lab directorship roles,
either in academia or industry is small.
And it was just last year
in the entire multi-sensory
history of US higher education
that we crossed the threshold
of a hundred US born
African-American women,
having attained PhDs in
physics or astronomy.
And so, even though our numbers are small,
black physicists have
played an important role
in the history of physics,
whether it be their roles
as sort of research associates in labs,
say students or postdocs
or their equivalent,
or as principal investigators
directing research labs.
And it turns out
that Yale has an important
role in the system.
The first Black American
to receive a PhD in the US
was a man by the name of Edward Bouchet,
and it was awarded in physics
by Yale in I believe 1876,
with its history as a
leader in many fields,
it's a great influence, not
only in the academic sphere,
but also in the larger societal sphere.
Yale is given its great resources
well-positioned to truly
lead and attracting
and importantly retaining diverse talent
that will level the playing field.
So yeah, with BlackInPhysics,
we're not only shining a light
on the important contributions
of these physicists
by for example, leading
Wikipedia editing campaigns
that produce pages for
accomplished scientists
who previously either had no page
or whose page was only sparsely populated,
but we also provide a microphone
to amplify the voices of these physicists,
who are widely read, highly
visible series of publications
that appear both in physics today
in physics world magazines,
which have global reach.
At this point we've reached a point
where we've made it difficult
to not see all of the many
talented black physicists
who are highly qualified
to hold principal investigating roles,
such as professorships
or staff scientist
positions at national labs,
or research team leads in industry.
And we've aided at making it quite clear
that the talent exists
and where to find it.
The next step
is to truly value black
physicist contributions,
and to understand that
in order to continue
to grow and be better,
physics as a discipline must make space,
healthy and welcoming space,
supportive and respectful
space for black physicists,
so that only can the
discipline reap the benefits
of our much needed perspective,
but also so that black physicists
can reap the socioeconomic benefit
of having highly valuable
technical knowledge
in a highly tech driven society
that constantly faces moral dilemmas
that affect many different
groups of people,
but typically only have
one group of people
making the decisions,
often with an unacceptably,
low understanding of how
people from different groups
are affected with those decisions.
I know that was sort of a long spiel,
but that's my take on BlackInPhysics,
and sort of that is why we
are doing what we are doing
and why our work is important.
- I really appreciate that.
And can you speak a little bit
to the way in which there's pressure
both from within and beyond
the academy around this?
I'm not a hundred percent sure
about your own experiences with this,
but you know, I know for graduate students
who are currently at Yale,
there's a lot of thought
into whether or not you
stay within the academy
and you become a faculty
member or to leave the academy.
And has that played a role at all
or has BlackInPhysics helped you navigate
the sort of career trajectory
that you've decided to pursue?
- Yeah, so I think BlackInPhysics
has helped me navigate
my career trajectory,
before BlackInPhysics,
it was the National Society
of Black Physicists.
And when I first started graduate school,
I had decided to go to graduate school
because I said to myself,
I want to work as a
professional physicist.
And typically in order to do
professional physicists work,
you would have a PhD,
and so I found myself in grad school.
Throughout my grad school process,
especially given the difficulties,
especially given, my difficulty with,
having a lot of messaging
that suggested that I
didn't belong in physics,
I sort of went through this
very windy rollercoaster
of, I need to get out of here ASAP,
and you know, I need to
be a part of academia,
and not only do excellent physics,
but also like really take part
in shepherding the future of the academy,
it's a very windy path between those two.
And when I first went
to the National Society of
Black Physicists conference,
which Meg Urry, actually
sort of made it happen.
That was my first time seeing
so many black scientists,
so many black physicists,
that was my first time meeting any,
and that was a completely
like life-changing experience.
And so that was something
that really like,
sort of put it in my mind and heart,
that this physics thing is
something that I can really do,
and I think that my
work with BlackInPhysics
has sort of further strengthen
that feeling in my mind
So now I'm sort of taking a
more of a leadership role.
I've sort of certainly benefit
from the resources that we provide,
but I'm gathering people,
I'm sort of deepening
my anchor to the field
and I'm helping pull up younger people
and trying to make sure at least
that some of the problems
that I dealt with
are less effective at pushing people out,
or maybe even upset.
- Very interesting, wow.
So I was reading your
physics today commentary
about disentangling, the
anti-blackness from physics,
and you cited how,
you were one of roughly
twenty-five black men
in Yale Grad School at the time 2015,
but you also just now
you talked about meeting
other like-minded people
and energized you and gave
you confidence and conviction.
So I'm curious how you
kind of transitioned
and got inspired to actually reaching out
and to build a community,
and what kind of advice you
would have for current students
who may have similar
experiences in grad school,
they may be in physics
or other science area,
and how like what ways then,
how can they also lend to build community
and leverage each other?
- So yeah, that's an excellent question,
incredibly important for students.
Really for everyone,
and it happens to turn
out that some of us,
in particular, ethnic
minorities or gender minorities
or other underrepresented folks on campus,
don't always find
themselves in communities
in the way that more represented people do
sort of automatically.
And so I made a point to build
community out of necessity,
because I didn't have it,
and I didn't initially
realize the importance of it,
and it really became clear that
I needed to be able to
talk to other people
about my experiences,
people that sort of automatically
understood my experiences,
definitely people who I could talk to,
that like didn't hold
preconceived notions,
say of my like intellectual abilities,
really could take me at face value
and respect me fully as a human
with an educated one
that has lots of useful
and important thoughts
to contribute.
And so my first sort of
major go with this at Yale
was the formation of the Yale
League of Black Scientists.
So this was a student group
that I formed with two
other Yale graduates.
One is my wife, Lindsay McMillan Brown,
who I believe is in the audience.
She got her PhD in chemical engineering
a little bit before me, I
can't remember when anymore,
but then also Brooke Russell
who got her PhD from Yale Physics,
and she was the first
black woman to get her PhD
from Yale Physics, she was in my cohort.
So we started this group and it was great
because it was a mechanism
through which we can apply
for funds in the university,
through the very nice
student group system at Yale,
in order to like create programming
that can support black STEM PhD students,
and that could be like sort
of professional development,
which we did, or also even social events,
because a lot of the
black students at Yale
were in humanities and social sciences,
and they're on a different part of campus.
So as a grad student
it's easy to be isolated,
if you're a black STEM PhD student,
I mean the combination of
being physically far away
from other black students,
and there being few
black STEM PhD students,
I mean, it's very, very
easy for you to be alone.
And so Yale League of Black Scientists
was a mechanism to produce programming
that sort of supported our
professional development
as PhD students, as black ones
that helped us socialize with each other,
and that kept us engaged
in the local community.
So another thing we did,
was we got very engaged with
the pathways to science office,
just sort of attached to the
main outreach arm of Yale,
and we were everywhere around the city,
we were in local schools
and we were interacting with
kids from local schools here,
not here not at Yale,
but on the Yale Campus.
And that was actually
a really important part
of providing anchors for us,
that sort of work made it clear
that our presence there was important,
and that we were making important changes.
And so this was sort of long winded,
but I can say that
community is super important
and everyone needs to win.
Some people sort of get it for free,
and it tends to be the case
that underrepresented people
have to work for it or even build it,
because in many cases it
doesn't already exist.
And so one good way for
students to find community
is to, well go run and look
for the resources that exists.
Yale has many excellent resources,
especially for students.
And if you find something
that you need doesn't exist,
build it, and I found that
there were many people,
both in the physics
department or higher up,
including Dean Cooley,
who supported the Yale
League of Black Scientists,
and try to make sure that we
had the resources we needed
to support ourselves.
This also means going
and talking with people,
leaning on people,
being authentic and real
about your experiences.
I mean, Yale students are strong students,
who have histories of
being strong students,
and sometimes go to yell
and have a hard time,
and can have a hard time,
being honest about having a hard time.
But I think in order to make
the sort of connections you
need and build a community,
you need to really thrive as a human,
you need to be open with
other people, reach out,
and let it be known
that it's okay to sort
of struggle with things.
And so that may involve
going and having real,
maybe even heartfelt
conversations with your peers
or reaching out to faculty.
That's something that I did a lot,
I was fortunate to have
a fantastic PhD advisor
who I spoke to about everything,
I was lucky to have that.
But there are other people
on the Yale Physics Faculty
that were incredible mentors to me,
that I reached out to about my issues,
and they supported me in
the way that they could.
And so that was another
way of building community,
and so my message to students would be,
identify the faculty that care about you,
there will be several
and there are well-resourced
influential and powerful people
that can make very serious
changes in your life
for the better.
- Wow, thank you for sharing,
I like what you said, being authentic,
be authentic about our hardship sometimes,
be willing to open up
and also to seek out.
Yeah, I think like I was
also in a way a minority
when I was there and, I
mean, I didn't know better,
I was speaking out and seeking out help.
So it it's great that you
had a great support system,
I mean, in the way you build it yourself,
you'll reach out to your advisor,
to other faculties and to fellow students
even in the humanities,
that's very impressive.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And actually, if I could add,
I'll say that our friends,
so, I'm speaking as a physicist,
I would say our friends
on the humanities and social sciences side
have been incredibly important to me
in a way that I couldn't
have known would be true
before I got to Yale,
and I had the privilege of
interacting with so many of them.
They gave me so many tools
to sort of contextualize
my experience as a human,
they gave me language to
talk about important issues,
and so, I would have been worse off
if I did not have the
fortune of interacting
with so many people
on the humanities and social science side.
Just wanna add that very
important, very important.
- [Jia] Thank you.
- Really appreciate your candidness
about all of this Charles,
and that vulnerability that
I think a lot of students
will empathize with and sympathize with.
And also, I just really commend
you on the ways in which
you were able during your time at Yale,
to reach out to so many communities,
you were talking a bit about community,
but the ways in which you created your,
well, you reached out to
the scholarly communities,
the National Society of
Black Physicists and others,
but also your department,
beyond your department,
the Graduate School Community,
but even the New Haven Community,
talking about the pathways
program, which is so wonderful,
and I think you're a model
of what we hope for
graduate students will do,
and to re emphasize that the Dean's office
is here to support students in that way.
It's a wonderful to hear stories
of students really taking advantage
of all there is to get out of this place.
And you've referred a couple
of times to mentorship,
and you even mentioned Meg Urry,
who I believe is on the call tonight.
And I wanted to ask you a
little bit specifically,
because on the one hand,
there is the building of communities,
but also I wanna ask you
about how you found mentors,
and we talked a lot about sort of peers
and finding your peers, but
finding good faculty members,
both as a graduate student,
and now as a postdoc,
as you grow in your own career,
how have your thoughts
about mentorship evolved
and how you see yourself as a mentor?
And can you speak a little bit to that?
- Yeah, so let me first say that,
unequivocally mentorship
is incredibly important,
and it's important for everyone,
and again, it turns out
to be the case that,
while mentorship is
important for everyone,
it's often that
underrepresented minorities
don't find themselves
in sort of important
mentorship relationship
that they need to thrive
in a way that more represented groups do,
some of which sort of
get it for free even.
So how did I end up having strong mentors?
It was born out of me being authentic,
and me asking for help.
Me describing the issues that I was having
and seeking people that
sort of could understand
what I was trying to describe,
didn't necessarily have
preconceived notions of,
I don't know, my background, my ability,
wouldn't necessarily be like,
"oh, you're just being sensitive,"
"that's not real,"
that really listened to me,
and I think I was fortunate
to get in a number of ways.
I mentioned that I had
a great PhD advisor,
and that was really
important to my experience
and I think not all
students are as fortunate
to have such a great advisor.
My PhD advisor was not
only a fantastic scientist,
but he is someone that like,
obviously very much cares about the people
that work in his group,
and he was very open to learning
a lot about my experience
throughout my time.
And he made it clear that
I could be open with him
about the difficulties that I was having,
and I did this with other faculty.
I already mentioned Meg, I
was a teaching fellow for Meg,
for definitely one semester,
and we were having a conversation
about women and physics,
and I think I said something like,
"okay, well, if you think
this about women in physics,
"what do you think about
black people and physics?"
And that turned into like
a five-hour conversation
in her office,
where I pretty much just unloaded
all of my difficulties
on Meg and she listened,
and she gave me lots of resources.
She made it happen
that I went to the National Society
of Black Physicist Conference,
and had this life changing experience.
So for me gaining mentors has again,
been being authentic about the
difficulties that I'm having
and asking for help,
and not necessarily being
stuck on having mentors
that look exactly like me.
I will be the first one to tell you that
role models are incredibly important,
and so for that reason,
Yale should continue its
work even more aggressively
to say diversify the faculty.
So I think it's important for students
like people who share my
identity, for example,
to see a role model that looks like that,
however, in the current landscape,
students, and really
everybody at all levels,
they need to be able to
identify what they need
and find mentors that
speak to different aspects
of their personality,
or that can provide different resources.
And so, what was the case for me
in my time at Yale and even now,
is me finding multiple mentors
that speak to different
parts of my identity,
as a physicists and as a human,
and together, I sort of have
all of my needs fulfilled
by this sort of network of mentorship,
and I think that
that's a really important
lesson for students.
Go and find people that care about you,
that can speak to different
parts of your identity,
and that will serve you incredibly well.
And again, I keep saying students,
but it's not just students,
like you still need
mentorship of your postdoc,
you still need mentorship if
you're a junior faculty member,
even if you're a full professor,
I mean, you're going to
be engaging in things
where there is some
more experienced person
that's not necessarily older than you,
but that can help guide
you through a process
where guiding is very necessary,
like this is sort of always the case.
So I think that message is
important really for everybody.
- Yeah.
- I often
tell graduate students, in fact,
that Yale is just made up of people,
and that that's how you sort
of have to navigate this place.
You can't just talk about
Yale as an entity on its own,
but it's actually made up of individuals
and sounds like you've met many of them
who have helped you in your career,
and now you're helping as an
alum, so we appreciate that.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So I think that was a multi-part question,
did I answer all the
parts of that question?
- Yeah, I think we hit on some topics,
and, well, there'll be more,
there's some questions
coming through on the chat,
I'll also put a plug in now,
so please continue submitting
questions to the Q and A,
but I'll pass it over
to Jia for the next one.
- Thank you, Matthew.
So, I was wondering, now
Charles, you're an alum now,
so maybe you are already
offering some help
and advice to students, fellow
students in physics today.
The other question is
you kind of touched upon
at the end of your last topic,
I'm combining this with a
question from Stephanie,
I mean, it takes a lot of initiative
to build that network
of the infrastructure,
the support system.
Now, what kind of advice do you have
from sort of an institution level
and an educational institution level,
what changes we need to put in place?
What kind of developments,
like what additional infrastructure
we should help to facilitate
to make this easier for
students to be inclusive,
for them, easy to find
the support they need.
- Yeah, so I think that, so to me,
and really important part of this is
diversifying at different levels.
So one thing that I think is really great
that the Physics Department
has achieved recently,
is really increasing the amount
of women in the department.
If I remember this,
I heard that the most
or the last incoming graduate school class
was maybe majority women,
maybe 55% women or something.
I think that's really
special for a department
that for a long time,
hadn't had very many women,
and that's important because,
it's more so the case that
new women who are students
can go in and see themselves represented,
they have more people that
can speak to their identity
that sort of understand
some of the struggles
that they go through.
There's already sort of a
foundation for community.
And that same kind of thing is important,
for example, for black
people, say me, for black men.
And so I think at multiple
levels, if we could have...
So let me just use this as an example,
because I think about physics,
and let me use my identity as an example.
What I'm saying is we need to
have more black undergraduates
in the physics department.
And so that means
we need to improve our
recruitment efforts,
we need to have more
black graduate students
in the physics department.
And so we need to improve
our recruitment efforts,
we need to have black postdocs
in the physics department.
And so we need to improve
our recruitment efforts,
and the same is true for faculty.
And I think like if you can
pull several individuals
that represent these different identities
into the department,
again, there's already a
foundation for our community,
and it will start to change
sort of department norms.
And then I felt like you're
getting into a situation
where it starts to become more practical
or at least easier to sort
of change the climate,
to change the environment.
When you're able to change norms
based off of having these
different groups needs met
in a way that's policy-based
and actually enforced,
I think you can start to
really create an environment
where people can sort of
leave baggage at the door.
So in physics, a lot of
physicists will tell you like,
"oh, you know physics
should be apolitical,"
blah, blah, blah,
but like physics, science
is all human endeavors.
There's so many aspects of our humanity,
so many aspects of society
that creep in the door,
and that includes things like bias.
And so if you're changing norms
and policies in your department,
that's sort of really can
leave bias at the door,
then you can have something like,
more physics interactions,
in a way that really
allows people to thrive.
So I think I'm always going to say
that we need to change norms and policies
along with bringing more
underrepresented groups in,
so that they can have the
climate that they need
to be respected and supported,
but then also make sure
that these people have
resources that they need,
which are gonna be different
for students or postdocs or faculty.
And I think that in my mind,
that's a very clear way
to really steer the
trajectory of the academy
as a whole in the right direction.
- Thank you, Charles, thank you.
A lot to think about how
to enhance the pipeline
and then really recruit diverse candidates
through all phases of
institution, so thank you.
- Which also might mean
bringing them in, in clusters.
And again, there are lots of resources,
there are lots of examples
of where these people are.
There are other things
that get in the way of bringing them in.
So we need to sort of attack
the problem more head on,
and bring in a lot of the talented people
that are known to exist,
like they definitely exist.
We need to bring them in
and change the climate
and make sure that they have the support
and respect and resources that they need.
- Oops, sorry Jia.
Your response made me think
of one of the questions
that was actually submitted in advance.
So I think I'll just ask that real quick,
and we'll sort of pivot to the
Q and A from the attendees.
And so someone had submitted
a question that reads,
"what two things would
you say to a URM student
"who is considering,
"but unsure about whether to
pursue a post-graduate degree
"in science and or physics
and why should they do it?"
I mean, I think it's a
really interesting question.
- Yeah.
So one thing that I sort of
time and time again come across
in my conversations with
underrepresented students
is concern with paying
for STEM grad school.
And so what's really important
for these students to know,
is that in almost all cases,
a STEM PhD will be funded,
so that you will have a stipend
that will support you
paying for living expenses,
food, and rent.
And it sort of depends on where you live,
whether or not that
compensation is enough,
there are many examples around the country
where students are working hard
to have higher compensation
to address issues with cost of living
for example, in the bay area,
the cost of living can be very, very high.
But underrepresented
students need to know that,
STEM PhDs are funded.
That's an important consideration for,
I think, many underrepresented students,
it certainly was for me,
as someone who, came
from humble beginnings
and certainly would be concerned about
say, taking out tens and
tens of thousands of dollars
in student loans in order
to pay for my education.
I think another important
reason to consider
doing a stem PhD,
is that in our society,
it being very technologically driven,
I would say it is clear
that more STEM education
needs some more socioeconomic mobility,
needs some more opportunities.
And again, as someone who
has for a long time,
not only loved physics,
but has thought it to be important
that I can have a career
where I could support myself,
and in the future support a family,
I think, one should really consider
that if you have passion to do STEM,
get the best and the highest
education that you can,
because that will really
not limit your potential
of what sort of work you can do,
your earning potential,
and the sort of opportunities generally,
you will have to move around
and have different sorts of jobs,
maybe doing hands-on science,
or maybe doing some leadership work,
leading teams of scientists.
So I think those are the two things
that sort of most quickly come to mind
that these STEM programs
tend to be funded,
and that having a large
amount of STEM education
will give you lots of economic
mobility in our society.
- I think those are
great pieces of advice,
and definitely the funding piece
is something we try to talk
about a lot during recruitment,
I think it's an unknown fact,
but we try and tell it to the world.
And I wanna pick up on one
other thing that you said,
you have this conviction
and it's actually come up a few times
about how you've always sort of known
that you wanted to be a physicist.
And another question that we received,
"given the scarcity of role models,
"can you speak to the
moment you became aware
"that you could become a physicist?"
- Yeah, that is such an
interesting question.
So I feel like I can answer
that in a number of ways
that aren't exactly
consistent with each other,
so let me try to give a bit of
context to what I might say.
In a sense I wanted to be a
physicist for my entire life
long before I actually knew what that was.
I was fortunate to have in my mother,
a role model who really loves science,
who wasn't a scientist herself,
but loved science loved to
talk to me about science.
And so that got me interested
in science very early,
and so I've been sort of
thinking about science
and dreaming of being a
scientist for a long time,
even though I didn't have
any role models around me
that were scientists,
nor that I interact with scientists,
and so I got to university.
So that is one answer,
the other answer is maybe
when I was in grad school
and I went to the National Society
of Black Physicists Conference.
And for the first time was in a room full
of many kinds of black
scientists, physicists
for physics, adjacent people
in engineering or chemistry,
or biological physics
who had very, very wide
backgrounds, very wide experiences,
some similar to mine, some very different,
but who all were in the same
room, talking about physics.
Working in different universities
or government labs or industry.
And so that was a very sort of
like self-image reaffirming experience,
like I've had this
feeling for a long time,
like, yeah, I wanna be a physicist.
I used to love Albert Einstein,
I used to love to read about his work
and read about black holes
and it was a sort of abstract thing,
and then I see all these physicists,
I'm like, wow, okay, this
is really a thing now.
So those, those are my
answers, those are my answers.
- I think those are great.
So this is a completely personal question,
but so how did that get into
your specific interests?
And I'm not gonna try and restate
what you said at the beginning
about your specific
work in graduate school,
but about like, which
sort of drew my attention,
I was really intrigued by that topic,
and the way that you were describing
what it can do with certain materials,
but was there a sort of
pathway that led you,
and I suppose part of the way
in which I'm framing this,
I could ask the question of
like, why did you choose Yale?
And like what brought you here
and how did you get interested
in the specifics of the work
that you were doing here?
- Yeah, so, you know, when
I first started college,
I was actually an engineering major,
and I quickly realized that,
I needed to change my path,
because it was the, how things worked,
that was the thing that
sort of drew me the most
that I was most passionate about.
Now with that,
I sort of have always been
interested in the foundations.
I like to think of myself
as an investigator,
as a sort of detective in a sense.
But instead of solving murders,
I'm trying to solve
mysteries of the universe,
and I happened to do
so through experiments.
I used to want to do so theoretically,
and so that has led to my interest
in the foundations of how things work.
So when I got to the
University of Minnesota
where I got my bachelor's degree,
and I took my first quantum physics class,
I had a great teacher, his
name is James Kakalios,
he's a condensed matter experimentalists
that works on different kinds of devices,
but he also cares a lot about Sci Com.
He wrote a popular science book called
"The Physics of Superheroes."
So that already sort of tells you
that he's developed his
ability to talk about science
and engage in work.
And he taught my quantum class,
and after that I was completely hooked.
I felt like I have to be
thinking about quantum mechanics
and quantum physics
for the rest of my life
after taking his class.
And so I had a research
experience with him,
so I was fortunate to get into his lab,
I had a summer research
experience funded by the NSF
in their research experience
for undergraduate program,
where I got to go to
U Chicago for a summer
and do some quantum related research.
I did a senior honors thesis
where I got to do other
kinds of materials,
quantum research.
And so when it was time for
me to go to grad school,
I was completely sold that I was gonna do
some sort of material physics thing.
But in my process of searching
for potential PhD advisor in grad school,
I came across Jack Harris,
who was my PhD advisor,
and I thought his work was incredible.
That was incredibly interesting,
I think when you come in
as a graduate student,
you're really wide-eyed and you
think everything is amazing,
and it's because everything is, right?
Yale faculty and other faculty elsewhere
do lots of very interesting science.
But I was convinced
that the person who became my PhD advisor
was incredibly interesting.
Now, a funny thing here,
is that I ended up working on
something completely different
in his group.
I had this opportunity to switch away
from doing material physics stuff,
to thinking about this, light
interacting with matter,
thinking about quantum mechanics,
thinking about how big a
quantum system could be,
which like really fulfilled my desire
to think about foundations in physics,
like deep, deep things about
why things are the way they are
and what they can be.
And so that's sort of what set me
on the quantum physics trajectory.
- I love that combination
of sort of breadth and depth
that as you sort of continued
going for the fundamentals,
you were also sort of trying
out all of these different ways
in which they can come
to bear, that's great.
So we've sort of touched on this broadly,
but there's a question that's
very specific to physics
and it's, what are some of
the challenges in your opinion
that black underrepresented
students and scientists face
in navigating the field?
So thinking really
specifically about physics,
are there particular things
that you think black students
and scientists are facing?
- Yeah, I think one of the biggest things
is perceptions of ability.
So unfortunately there,
many aspects of society
tend to want to force
black people in particular
into a certain box,
and that box does not include
attributes like smart.
And that is a very real thing
that you feel immediately
when you walk into an
environment like Yale,
where intelligence is sort of a currency.
Well, that's one of the main ways
by which you evaluate
a peer or a near peer
or someone you either
outrank or who outranks you.
And so certainly perceived intelligence
or perceived incompetence is a difficulty.
It also turns out that race and
class, socioeconomic status,
are sort of all wound
up in the United States,
and it also turns out that
that can mean that for some students,
some under represented
students, some blacks students,
they could come up in
an educational system
that lacked important resources.
And so I think what that means is,
sometimes, I'm gonna really
careful about how I say this.
I think that means that sometimes
students can find that they
have different preparation
than other students,
and sometimes they're not
in teaching environments
where the teaching is sort
of cognizant of that fact.
So sometimes you end up in a classroom
where students have different preparation,
and it's not always the case
that the teaching is
geared towards sort of
meeting people where they
are and building them up.
Sometimes teaching can speak to
only the students who have
had the most resources
that come from the most
well-funded school districts,
that have the wealthy people
who can pay the taxes,
which then go and fund the schools,
that give some students,
all these extra resources
compared to other students.
And that leads to
differences in preparation
when going into next steps.
That's an issue, that's
a sort of bigger one,
that's a, society-wide, that's a funding,
that's a, how do we,
yeah, that's a tough one,
but that's important.
And again, I've already
mentioned about community,
again, it's easy to come into a situation
where you were the only person.
For over a decade,
I have almost always been
the only person like me
in the room.
And it's really hard to
have that identity sometimes
because I can tell you when
I was a younger grad student,
I was definitely afraid
of making a mistake
and convincing everyone around me
that what people thought
about black people was true.
That if I was to fail a test, for example,
it would only suggest that,
it is indeed the case that black
people cannot be physicist,
because you don't see
them anywhere, right?
And people already sort
of hold these notions
sometimes about us.
And so black students or LGBTQ students
or students with various disabilities,
can sometimes carry this weight
where they don't see role models,
people already don't think that
they belong in these spaces,
and it's really hard for them to feel like
they can actually be
human and make mistakes
without confirming that
they indeed do not belong.
And so that is a huge challenge
that you sort of always face
when you're underrepresented students.
I think I'll maybe I'll stop there,
I can keep on going but I should stop.
- No, I definitely, I appreciate that.
And the ways in which
we have this complicated
situation in graduate school,
where there is this sort of,
the way in which your
intelligence is perceived
is not always accurate,
and then there's also imposter
syndrome on top of that
and how those two things
play with one another,
and that pressure
that so many underrepresented
students feel
to actually be the best,
and all of that combined creates
this stressful environment,
so often, I really appreciate
you speaking about it.
So I think we'll Jia,
I see put a question in the chat
so maybe we'll use that
as our final question,
which is, "what is your next move,
"academia, industry, nonprofit,
"are you thinking about this?"
"How are you thinking about this?"
I think this is a question
that our students are
constantly wondering themselves.
- Yeah, so I'm thinking about this a lot,
and I've been thinking
about it for a long time.
Academia all the way.
So I'm positive that I want to
be a professional physicist,
I could do so in academia.
I also think that the
university system globally
is incredibly important.
I think it's one of the
most important things
that humanity has done,
and I really want to take a part
in being a thought leader in
physics and quantum science,
but also being part of the leadership
of the university system,
again, shepherding it into the future,
making sure that
the university continues
to be like a hotbed
for the production of knowledge.
This is important for
just how we understand
our place in the universe as humans,
but then also for how we
say produce technology
that goes and enriches lives.
And I think it's important for us to do so
in a way that's equitable,
that is not like increasing
or driving disparities
in different people's experiences,
doing so in a way that
levels the playing field,
that enriches people's lives.
And I wanna take a part in
making sure the university
that I'm at in the future
as a faculty member,
and that does that,
and I wanna sort of take
the role as a leadership,
the role of a leader
and sort of be a role
model as a faculty member,
maybe for other faculty members,
regarding what being an effective
faculty member looks like.
I don't believe
that that is just being excellent
at science as a physicist,
I think it's being excellent at science,
being a good teacher, being a good human
that cares about making sure that
different people from
different backgrounds
are in an inclusive space
that respects them as people,
that really provides them
with the resources to thrive.
So yeah, I'm gonna be a professor,
I'm looking forward to it (laughs).
- That's a fantastic
answer, thank you so much,
and we need you, so we appreciate
that path ahead of you.
- [Charles] Thank you.
- I wanna thank Dean Cooley,
I wanna thank Charles and Jia
for their remarks in this
conversation tonight,
and also to all the students
and alumni who joined us,
thank you for being here.
Thanks also to my colleagues, Yasmina
(indistinct), Regan and Kathleen Galo
for all their hard work in
putting this event together,
along with the GSAA.
I hope everyone has
enjoyed the conversation
and will continue to help us
build a stronger community
among graduate student's
faculty, and alumni.
So thank you again,
especially Charles, thank you.
We hope that you'll all join us
for our next event in
the perspectives series
with Lindsay McMillan Brown,
name you might've heard earlier today,
who's also class of 2019
PhD in chemical engineering,
who's working as a research engineer
at the NASA Glenn Research
Center in Cleveland.
And that conversation will take place
on December 8th at 8:00 p.m.
More info will be sent out by email.
I also encourage anyone who
has not already done so,
to join Cross Campus or to log in
if you haven't done so in a little while.
Cross Campus, as you may know,
is a fantastic way for alumni and students
to connect with one another
formally or informally.
And if there are other ways
in which you'd like to be more involved
in supporting the graduate school,
please don't hesitate to reach
out to me and my colleagues,
we'd love to hear from you.
We look forward to seeing
everyone again soon
for our next conversation
in the prospective series.
Thank you everyone, and have a good night.
- [Charles] Thank you.
- Thank you.